s'il s'en tient à l'air un peu perdu
c'est parce qu'elle est à la recherche
de sa marraine comme ces dix sept
camarades elle s'est portée volontaire
pour en apprendre davantage sur
l'entreprise thalès basé à elancourt ce
projet en fait nous
ouvre au monde extérieur sur tout le
monde professionnel et ça nous fait un
gros carnet d adresse puisque qu en
troisième on n'a pas beaucoup de contact
avec le monde extérieur
chaque parrain ou marraine a reçu un kit
avec un contrat d'engagement qui permet
de formaliser ce tutorat il prévoit
notamment un rendez vous mensuel
ça apporte une vraie valeur humaine
aussi parce que l'on s'intéresse à leur
projet à ce qu'ils veulent faire ce
qu'ils font déjà dans la vie que ça soit
au collège vendeur du collège leur
activité ça permet un échange
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'un
partenariat est conclu entre
l'entreprise thales et le collège
gustave courbet l'an dernier les deux
établissements avaient collaboré dans le
cadre du projet grain d'entreprise en
fait les salariés sont dit pourquoi pas
s'engager auprès d'élèves pour un peu
travaillé leur orientation et ce sur
peut-être plusieurs années donc
l'objectif c'est que là là on fait le
lancement des binômes exerce à elle
jusqu'à l'obtention du brevet voire même
du bac on a des gens qui sont passionnés
dans le groupe thales
donc on va pouvoir créer ses relations
entre le salarié et l'élève pour le
faire découvrir une vocation peut-être
d'un groupe thales au delà de la
découverte des filières industrie et
technique
cette action a également pour objectif
de construire un parcours d'orientation
scolaire et de développer chez les
collégiens un esprit d'initiative